by now you've heard sentinels will not
be making it to masters after some tough
playoff losses and like esports always
does there have been plenty of hot takes
about the end of the sentinel's era but
i am here to do something that almost
never happens provide a reasonable take
did sentinels underperform absolutely
and i think they would be the first to
tell you that does that mean that
they're washed and should blow up their
entire roster no the the answer is no
first let's remember that this is
valerian's second competitive year
things balance out new metas and bright
stars emerge and most importantly teams
catch up to the big dogs which is why we
need to give credit where credit is due
version 1 and the guard are fantastic
teams that have played and prepped
incredibly well and deserve kudos for
that but does that mean sentinels are
bad no and it's not a bad thing that
they lost we should be excited there are
so many great teams out there and not
just one team dominating the scene i
want something exciting don't you